hopefully
what's up
um good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
thank you all for coming
um you know I'm standing here with uh my
law enforcement Partners in the Gilgo
task force uh to announce uh the
indictment of defendant Rex Andrew
heermann 59 years of age uh he's been
arrested by the Suffolk County Police
Department's homicide detectives and
he's been indicted uh in a grand jury
present a presentation by the Suffolk
County District Attorney's office for
the murders of Melissa Bartholomew Megan
Waterman and Amber Costello the
investigation of Maureen Brainerd Barnes
is ongoing these young women went
missing between July of 2007 and
September of 2010. they were found in
December of 2010 by the Suffolk County
Police Department and then there was
nothing absolutely nothing for their for
the next 13 years their cases
went unsolved
until today
when I took office in January of 2022 I
made uh Gilgo a priority I made Gilgo a
priority before I took office I met with
the victims families uh some of whom I'm
proud to have standing with us today and
I told them that we were going to handle
this case differently we were going to
do it differently and that when I showed
up
you aren't going to see me calling the
media and being on Gilgo Beach with a
giant
magnifying lens looking for Clues 12
years after the case what I was going to
do was I was going to work with my task
force we were going to form a task force
we're going to work with the Suffolk
County Police Department we were going
to work with the Suffolk County
Sheriff's Office we're going to work
with the New York State Police we're
going to work with our FBI and we're
going to form this task force and we're
going to work together and we were going
to we were going to use the grand jury
the power of the grand jury to cut to to
reach a determination in this case
because the grand jury has two things it
has power it has reach you can obtain
documents you could interview Witnesses
but the other thing that the grand jury
has
the grand jury has secrecy no one knows
what you do when you operate a grand
jury proceeding and we knew that when we
were investigating this case and it when
we dealt with the media or whatever it
was we were doing
um we were we were playing uh before a
party of one
because we knew uh the person
responsible for these murders would be
looking at us so we were very careful uh
how we we handled the investigation we
maintained the Integrity of the
investigation uh most importantly most
importantly of all we maintain the
secrecy of that investigation and I
think that's uh that's paid dividends as
we've seen today
now
um
I
you know I I think that uh you know when
we had
the uh the task force uh the first thing
we did got together with uh um Suffolk
County Police Commissioner Rodney
Harrison and we formed the task force
our first meeting uh was February
February 1st of 2022. and what we did
what all of the agencies here we made
the commitment we were going to take our
talented our most talented investigators
so in the district attorney's office we
took uh Ada's myself included we took
analysts we took detective investigators
and they worked on a daily basis with
other talented investigators from all of
the agencies here
um and uh we started that in February
1st in 2022
six weeks later on March 14th
2022 the name Rex Sherman was first
mentioned as a suspect uh in the Gilgo
case
a New York State uh investigator was
able to uh to
identify him in a database
and from that point on we used the power
of the grand jury over 300 subpoenas and
search warrants looking into this this
individual's background to bring us to
this day
so I'm I am uh I'm proud I I know that
this case is over but I'm proud of what
we've accomplished up to this point I
know we have more to accomplish but I'm
also uh thankful thankful for the
partnership of of the task force because
certainly without the participation of
the task force we wouldn't be standing
here
um you know before I I you know I thank
some some folks and and turn it over to
uh to uh our our partners I just want to
talk a little bit about the the evidence
in the case uh I know a lot of people
know about the case as I indicated uh
the uh the victims went missing between
July of 2010 and September uh I'm sorry
July of 2007 and uh September of 2010 uh
and uh in December of 2010 they were uh
their their bodies were recovered uh
they were buried in a similar fashion in
a similar location
um uh in in a similar way all the women
were petite uh they were
um they they all did the same thing for
a living uh they all advertise the same
way uh and they were uh immediately
there were similarities with regard uh
to the to the uh the crime scenes uh all
the women's all the women were bound at
the head uh at the midsection uh or at
the chest and later at the legs
um the other thing I think that that
um uh was was that's been talked about
in the uh in the media was they were
Bound by
um burlap uh me uh that has taken a life
of its own in the media and the burlap
has has been described or thought to be
uh the burlap that's used at a nursery
for uh that's not the burlap that was
used in this case the burlap is it was
camouflage burlap uh used for duck
blinds of hunting
so uh I obviously it it was used to hide
uh purposely hide the bodies
um one thing that became immediately
apparent uh was at the time of the of
each of the murders uh the murderer the
the defendant human uh he got a a
you got a cell phone uh and a burner
phone which uh which is prepaid and
Anonymous and for each of the murders he
got an individual burner phone and he
used that to communicate with the
victims uh then shortly after uh the
death of the victims uh he then would uh
would get rid of the burner foam
uh and uh right away in December of 2012
uh FBI uh cast analysts special agents
with the cast unit of the FBI they
immediately began looking at that sell
site uh uh data they've compared the
victims phones with uh with the burner
phones and they immediately honed in on
some some similarities specifically uh
in the Massapequa Park area and they
looked at the an area of a Confluence of
four cell towers uh and they realized
that this was had uh significance
because uh the the uh perpetrator of
these crimes was probably located within
this area uh during at or around the
times of the murderer and that was
mapped out that was called the box and
it was an area uh in Massapequa Park the
FBI also managed to do that for an area
in mid Midtown Manhattan
um and so that was that was an
investigative lead the other uh
investigative lead at the time was even
though there was a significant amount of
time that elapsed with regard to uh
before the the uh the victims were
recovered there was some uh some
significant evidence recovered uh
specifically there was a uh um hair
recovered from Maureen Brainerd Barnes
from a belt buckle that was around her
legs uh there uh with regard to Megan
Waterman uh there were three hairs
recovered
um uh from from her uh one uh from
around her head area one from around her
her leg area in the burlap and then
there was one caught in between the tape
uh and uh that was recovered uh amber
Costello also had a hair a significant
hair that was recovered uh during the
time
uh during the time of the recovery but
uh again uh the crime scene because it
was out there for so long and because uh
it was exposed to the elements uh those
hairs were degraded so you couldn't use
traditional DNA
um analysis on it you would uh you would
have to wait and use mitochondrial DNA
and back in 2010 the technology wasn't
there for mitochondrial DNA so the
investigation proceeded but also
technology preceded as well
uh and then in January and February of
2022 we've we've formed the task force
we began working uh collectively uh and
then near six weeks later on March 14
2022 Rex yerman was identified for the
first time uh and the manner in which
that was done was uh the New York State
investigator looked at a database uh
amber Costello the day before her uh
disappearance on September 1st uh 2010
uh she uh uh she met with an individual
for the purposes of of having him pay
her money uh for for her Services
um but she uh she would involve if she
involved herself in a roost where once
the the individual gave her uh gave her
money and uh other individuals came into
the the house pretended to be
significant others confronted the
individual uh with the purpose of of
making that individual uncomfortable
having him leave without retrieving his
money and that's exactly what happened
uh so uh that individual was identified
as as a person who was between six four
and six six uh a a large man thickly
built not necessarily overly muscular
but just a naturally a big person with
glasses white uh and and dark hair
uh also of significance was
um that the fact that he was driving a
dark colored or black uh uh first uh a
first generation Chevrolet Avalanche
with a a very uh unique feature that was
between the it was a pickup truck so it
was between the cab and the bed and that
was identified again that was back uh in
uh 2010. but it wasn't until uh March of
of 2022 uh that that database uh was by
was was this was searched uh by the the
task force uh and this individual uh uh
was was identified uh that I uh that
individual was uh Rex Sherman the
defendant and right away there were some
commonalities that came right to the
full REX German 6-4 largely uh a large
person not necessarily uh muscular but a
very uh physically large person uh he
has glasses uh he has he has that the
dark hair and also a particular note he
owned at the time that first generation
Chevy Avalanche but there was more uh he
lived at 105 First Avenue which was
located within that box area that the
FBI first uh discovered in in 2012.
uh but there was more uh also he worked
at the time at an architect as an art
and uh he owned his own architectural
firm uh and an address at 19 West 36th
Street in Midnight Midtown Manhattan and
that was also the area of interest that
was identified by the FBI in 2012.
again that was March 14 2022 uh and from
that point on our our partners and my
office we use the grand jury to continue
to investigate and we executed over 300
subpoenas search warrants pertaining to
this individual to find out more
information
uh one of the things that we did is we
followed him because we wanted to get an
abandonment sample of his DNA
which we were able to do
we also got uh DNA samples abandonment
samples from his family and then we went
back and we got mitochondrial DNA
testing and with regard to
um you know and you know
there's an inch there's a an aspect of
New York state law that doesn't allow me
to talk about uh DNA testing uh
specifically at press conferences it's
um so I can't do that however at the
um at the uh arraignment and also when
we filed our bail letter we talked about
the significance of that evidence so if
anyone needs to see that but but uh
suffice to say uh that evidence was
significant uh especially with regard to
uh the other evidence that we had
developed but it was uh there was uh
another interesting aspect we looked at
the yerman Family Travel records and we
learned that during the murders of uh
the last three women
um Bartholome Waterman and Costello that
during the commission of those murders
the the uh the defendant's wife and
children were were out of New York State
and he was alone in the tri-state area
uh we also went back and looked at his
cell site records and we were we we
compared his personal cell site records
with that of the four Target phones and
we saw that there was areas of
commonality in other words that whenever
the the Target phones would uh would
would bounce off a cell tower if if the
uh German uh personal phone uh bounced
off a tower it was always consistent and
in close proximity uh with the Target
phones and at no time was there ever an
instant where those Target phones were
for instance in New Jersey while uh the
defendant was was on Long Island so that
was completely
um consistent the other thing that we
looked at was uh we looked at his use of
burner phones
uh and we we followed using the grand
jury using the great investigative help
from our partners we followed his use of
burner phones we were able to identify
seven separate burner phones that he
used we were able to use fictitious or
fraudulent email addresses and get
Google warrants and from there we got
his searches
uh and we learned uh what we what uh the
individ of what the defendant was
searching uh in a 14-month period he had
over 200 searches pertaining to uh the
Gilgo investigation uh not only without
uh was he looking at uh investigative
Insight uh he was looking trying to
figure out how is the Task Force using
cell phones to try to figure out what's
happening what are the developments with
regard to the task force and this uh
this really
um
um supported our decision to keep our
investigative
Focus secret because we knew that one
person would be watching and we didn't
want to give him uh any insight into
what we were doing and we also didn't
want him to know just how close we were
getting so we maintained the the grand
jury secrecy and we maintain the
Integrity of our investigation
uh in addition to those those uh
um Gilgo searches he was searching
compulsively searching pictures of the
victims but not only pictures of the
victims pictures of their uh their uh
relatives their their their sisters
uh their children and he was trying to
locate those individuals
in addition to that there was a lot of
torture
uh porn and and uh um what you would
consider uh you know uh
um depictions of women uh being abused
uh being raped and being killed
in addition to all of that we continue
to look uh and uh
we were able to uh determine uh that
that Chevy Avalanche that was used
during the commission of the Amber
Costello crime uh that Chevy Avalanche
was in South Carolina and again with the
help of our partners we were able to
capture uh we were able to seize that uh
Chevy Avalanche pursuant to a search
warrant and we're certainly going to
analyze that in addition to that uh
pursuant to the arrest of the defendant
last night by the Suffolk County Police
Department we we obtained one of his
burner Thrones his last burner phones
the investigate as I said the this case
is not over it's only beginning we're
continuing to execute search warrants
and we anticipate getting more evidence
uh before I I turn it over to my
partners I I wanna I Wanna Thank A lot
of people in the room first and foremost
I want to thank the victims in this case
you know it's always inspiring as a
prosecutor when you get to meet uh the
victims uh and while sometimes our
defendants could embody the very worst
of humanity it seems that invariably our
victims embody the very best of what it
means uh to be human and in this case it
was no no different I've gotten to know
the families and I'm inspired by them
and I'm impressed by their patients uh
and by their their dogged persistence
and not only supporting uh their their
lost uh sisters or or or or mother uh or
or daughter but also really uh you know
freely standing for victims at
everywhere so I I wanna I wanna I wanna
thank them all uh so much
uh and I want to let them know that
we're going to continue to work this
case
um the next thing I want to do I just
want to thank I want to thank our
partners I want to thank uh Suffolk
County Police Commissioner Rodney
Harrison
um you know we said it was a change and
when we talked about you know not going
before the media if you see
um you know Rodney did go before the
media uh but it was always in a very
controlled Manner and it was always with
the control purpose again
we did that because we knew we were
playing before a an audience of one
person uh and so I want to thank Rodney
for his partnership uh most importantly
I want to thank Rodney for his Integrity
I think in the past
what the reason why uh uh
these various investigations fell short
was because there was a lot of outside
influence a lot of people who had
nothing to do with the investigation
nothing to do with the um
uh the the investigation or any of the
agencies that were actually handling the
investigation they still asserted
pressure on those investigations that
did not happen with our task force our
task force was won by our members and we
did what we thought was in the best uh
the best investigative steps and what
was in the best interest of the of the
interaction so I want to thank Rodney
for that
uh and his whole team I I know that we
have Suffolk County homicide here Kevin
Beyer uh we we've got inspector Rowan
and I know that they've been around and
I know that they're here and I know that
they stand in the shoes of their past
investigators and I want to congratulate
them and I want to thank them for their
partnership
I also want to thank uh uh Sheriff Errol
Toulon everything I said about Rodney I
could say about Errol uh Errol uh is an
unbelievable partner he was an
unbelievable partner in this case uh
during the dependency of this case and
one of the reasons why we had to take
this case down was we learned that the
defendant was using these alternate uh
um identities and these alternate
instruments that continue to patronize
sex workers
which of course made us very nervous uh
but with with the help of of
um the sheriff and his database and his
analysts we were able to continually
stay uh one uh one step ahead of the
defendant so so thank you uh Sheriff
Toulon I want to thank
um the FBI I know
um assistant director in charge Michael
brodak is here I want to thank his
entire team you know when you have the
FBI not only do you have tremendous
resources uh and insight uh whether it's
the behavioral sciences unit whether
it's cast uh whether it's cart which is
their computer unit but you also have
the ability to seize a car in South
Carolina I can't seize a car in South
Carolina without the FBI so so thank you
for that and thank you for your
partnership and thank you for for your
willingness uh to work with us I want to
I want to thank the New York state
troopers uh I know major yudice is here
and his team uh you know uh this case is
is emblematic of of great cooperation
but we always get that same level of
cooperation from the state police no
matter what uh case we're working so I
want to thank them their investigators
did a great uh um did great work on this
job and uh in this case and we couldn't
have done it without them lastly I want
to thank Nassau County Police
Commissioner Pat Ryder I don't know if
he's here did he make it
um you know this this case as I said
spans you know 13 years and during that
time
um you know Pat Ryder has been our
neighbor to the west when it started I
think he was a sergeant uh to Texas Art
and maybe uh uniform Sergeant but
whatever whenever we needed something to
be done or whenever the task force
needed uh something to be done uh Pat
Ryder would do it and he would do it
quietly without much fanfare and we know
he would keep the confidentiality of our
grand jury and our investigation so I
want to thank him for that
um and with that I will turn it over to
uh commissioner Rodney Harrison
it's good afternoon
today is a good day
and before I acknowledge the individuals
that had a role in get into this place
I would first and foremost
like to offer my deepest condolences
to the family members
to the family members of Amber Costello
Melissa Bartholomew
Megan Waterman
I Can Only Imagine
what you had to adore
over the last decade
regarding knowing that your killer was
still loose
God bless you
push
thank you for your patience
so I've I've had the privilege of being
the
police Commissioners nearly about two
years now and I have had that
investigative experience in the NYPD
as a detective
as the chief of detectives
and when I was going through the process
of being a police commissioner my
engagement with the county executive was
I was very familiar
with this unfortunate homicide homicides
and I wanted to let it be known that
this was going to be our number one
priority
but I also want to make this very clear
that this arrest was made
by the investigators
assigned to the task force
I announced during a press conference 18
months ago
about a new team effort
that was going to investigate the
homicide and that was going to consist
of
people from
Ray attorney's office
from Mike Braddock FBI Mike thank you so
much
State Police Steve
appreciate your support
Dr Earl Toulon Jr
thank you sir
as well as the investigators from
the homicide detectives in Suffolk
County
gentlemen thank you
for all you've done working together
with us making sure we are here today
I also want to thank my partner
Pat Ryder Pat good seeing you man
and uh former NYPD police commissioner
kishang Sewell
for providing resources to assist in the
investigation that brought us here today
so
one of my first acts was to survey the
scene
when I first got assigned as a police
commissioner me and Kevin Breyer went
over to Gilgo Beach
I want to thank heaven
you know when I first met Kevin he broke
the whole case down and where we stood
he knew the case like the back of his
hand he worked tirelessly in his case
uh Kev was in charge of overseeing the
task force since his creation and you
did a phenomenal Jack Kev thank you
so there's something that I learned
from a
former
NYPD police commissioner
James O'Neill
which is in order to fight crime or to
solve investigations you have to make
sure you're working with your law
enforcement partners
the blueprint in making this arrest
was a whole team effort
everybody left their Eagles at the door
and made sure that they brought the
knowledge and the resources to this
investigation
fresh eyes on his case
and the resiliency of our investigators
allowed us to identify
Rex Herriman
ladies and gentlemen
Rex Sherman is a demon
that walks Among Us
a predator
that ruined families
if not for the members of this task
force
he would still be on the streets today
however even with this arrest
we're not done
there's more work to do in this
investigation regarding the other
victims
of the Gilgo Beach Bodies that were
discovered
I'm going to encourage anybody that
still has information
call our Crime Stoppers hotline
1-800-220-tips
I want to recognize and thank my chief
of detectives John
thank you for your great work
Deputy Police Commissioner Anthony
Carter
both of you who provided
update
information regarding the case
and let it be known if there was any
resources that they needed that
you brought it to my attention
since the discovery of the first victim
there's been a lot of scrutiny
and criticism
regarding how this investigation was
handled
I will tell you this
the investigators
were never discouraged
they continued and and uncovered
evidence and followed the leads
they never stop working
and will continue to work tirelessly
until we bring
justice to all the families involved
last but not least I want to thank my
predecessors
that came before me the work that they
did
I want to thank them
for really laying the foundation that
helped us get to here today
thanks Ryan
foreign
good afternoon
my name is Michael brodak I'm the FBI
special agent in charge of the New York
office's Criminal Division
the FBI expanded its full set of
resources in support of our local and
state Partners to advance this
investigation
the charges show that we can overcome
the most difficult challenges
when federal state and local law
enforcement work together under one task
force
while nothing can fill the void caused
by the loss of a loved one
through today's announcement
we are hopeful
that the families of the victims begin
to experience a sense of peace
closure
and justice
and that the general public feels safer
knowing that an alleged
killer
is no longer roaming free
the action is taken today should serve
as a reminder that the FBI along with
our law enforcement Partners will
continue to be Resolute in our
determination
to bring all offenders to Justice no
matter how many years has passed
I would like to thank Suffolk County
district attorney Ray Tierney and his
prosecution team Suffolk County Police
Commissioner Rodney Harrison and the
Suffolk County Police Department the New
York State Police
and the investigators and staff of the
FBI New York field office including the
Long Island violent crime task force
thank you
good afternoon my name is Dr Earl D
Toulon Jr and I'm the sheriff of Suffolk
County I would profoundly like to thank
the district attorney and the police
commissioner for including me not only
here today but for including the Suffolk
County Sheriff's Office and recognizing
the importance of jail intelligence it
is extremely important when you realize
that we created our human trafficking
unit in 2018
that there are victims in our community
and that intelligence is being shared by
many of the men and women who are
incarcerated today and we have seen many
disjointed investigations occur and
leading up to the leadership of these
two men have really brought everything
together
I am proud that today we stand here a
little bit closer to Bringing closure to
the families and extend my deepest
condolences to all of you
because of the nature of this case
and recognizing that human trafficking
and Corrections intelligence is so
important we realize that there are many
other cases that are going on that will
we will help to solve going forward so I
thank my intelligence staff and team
that are here today for the diligence
and their work
while we did our part in this
investigation we continue because we
have to house this individual
we have already designated uh or talked
about certain locations where we will
house them and in addition the security
measures we will Implement in our
facility uh to make sure that this
individual is brought to Justice the way
he should be
thank you very much and have a good day
good afternoon uh I'm Colonel Richard
Allen I'm the field commander with the
state police and I want to start by
expressing my my sincere condolences to
the family members that are here today
although losing a loved one you can
never
completely get rid of that pain but
hopefully these steps that are taken
here today are a step in the right
direction for you to start in the
healing process or work through the
healing process I want to thank the
members of the task force all the
agencies you see behind me when we were
approached in 2022 to be part of this
task force we were fully engaged I'm
glad to be part of this and we we
assigned investigators on a full-time
basis you know what you see
um
being done here today is the end game of
agencies working together as it was said
before with no ego was all egos put
aside with the sole mission to find
Justice for these victims you know um
here in troopel
major Steven Eunice oversees the
operations down here he has been
intricately involved in this task force
since we became partners with it and I'm
going to ask him to come up and say a
few words or expand upon this a little
bit of our role in the task force
thank you
thank you colonel
good afternoon I'm major Steve eutis New
York State Police Troop Bell Long Island
troop Commander I'd like to take this
opportunity to start off by
acknowledging the D.A Ray Tierney and
commissioner Rodney Harrison for having
the vision to see that forming a task
force might breed new light into this
investigation
the state police were asked in early
2022 to join this task force and once
requested we were more than willing to
do so
we were also very pleased
that we were able to make some very
meaningful contributions in this case
to help Propel it forward
I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank all of the task force members from
the different agencies and congratulate
them on a job well done
I think this case represents an example
of what we as law enforcement can do
when we pull our resources together and
we work together
I would also like to mention the state
police member assigned to this task
force
you were provided with a mission and
that mission was
to participate in this task force
put everything else that you were doing
aside
assume a place 100 percent of your
attention on this case and help push
this case forward
you more than accomplish that mission
I congratulate you on a job well done
and I commend you for your outstanding
work
to the families I'd like to say that on
my behalf of myself and the New York
State Police we offer you our deepest
condolences
we recognize that these crimes may have
happened years ago but that pain
continues
our hope is that this development today
provides you with some relief and some
comfort knowing that the person
responsible for the for your loved one's
death is now being held accountable and
he's no longer a threat to anyone else
in society
I want you to know additionally that the
state police is not done here
we are remaining committed and will
continue to support the Suffolk County
District Attorney's Office the Suffolk
County Police Department and this task
force as we move into the next phase of
this process that's the prosecution
I would also like to say something to
everyone watching this with us today
there's been a lot of discussion here
today about charges about the suspect
about what happened but I would also
like everybody to take the time to join
with me and keep the families of the
victims and the victims themselves in
your thoughts and in your prayers
each one of these victims was a family
member and a loved one and their void
and their loss caused Great pain and
they did not deserve this nobody is
deserving of this we hope this
development today will bring some
comfort to them as they move forward
thank you
does anybody have any questions
you know sure before I do that I just
you know I'm standing back I realized I
didn't thank my own team
um so
uh so I I want to thank uh I want to
thank my chief investigator Rich
zacharis uh who is uh without uh I am so
lucky to have I want to thank uh Nick
Santo Martino Ada Nick Santa Martino uh
Ada Michelle Haddad Ada uh Andrew Lee uh
I also want to thank my chief uh
assistant uh Alan Bodie and I want to
thank all of the incredible incredible
analysts uh that we have working for us
at the Suffolk County DA's office so uh
having said that I'll not answer your
question
um so uh you know I think that there was
attention in in in the task force and it
was it was a it was a good tension uh
because you know there's a tension
between getting the the evidence
necessary to charge somebody but also
keeping the public safe and that's the
tension that we always deal with so as
we were working forward we were and and
you know we had uh Suffolk County PD we
had the FBI surveilling the defendant
obviously I can't be all the time but we
were you know we were reasonably assured
with that but this individual was was
was a person that continued to patronize
sex workers at all hours of the night uh
he continued to use fictitious
um
email addresses fictitious identities
burner phones and so as we we worked
through the case and we got closer and
closer all of a sudden and we built the
evidence suddenly the balance tips uh in
favor of of Public Safety so uh you know
I think we we wanted we all wanted as a
task force to continue it but I think
collectively we felt that it was time uh
to to you know to strike that balance
and and to take him off the street so
that's what we did yeah
I I don't believe they uh does that does
anyone anybody want to say anything
no they're they're here they're there I
could tell you they're the watermen uh
uh Bartholomew and Brainerd Barnes
family members but uh they're here uh
they're here first and foremost to
support uh their loved ones and we're
we're happy and grateful to have them
here
the uh this this portion had to deal
with the deaths of these four young
women uh and that's what we focused on
that was what the grand jury
investigation was focused on I talked
about the commonalities uh and the
commonalities uh all those commonalities
that we talked to were uh unique to
these uh four separate cases uh so
that's what we're working on I think the
other members of the task force said you
know we're going to continue uh you know
and continue to work and investigate and
try to get a small measure of closure
for all the victims families but for
right now uh this defendant uh it's this
defendant with these these these uh
these four victims
term in any other remains remains other
than
um I'm I'm here to talk about
uh what we did with regard to these four
victims and as I I opened my my
um
my ad address by talking about the need
to maintain uh investigative secrecy so
we are going to maintain that
investigative secrecy and when I talk
about other individuals and other cases
it will be after they have uh they have
handcuffs on
New York State officer made the link
with her many looked at data and that's
when Herman came up shortly after the
task force the uh
so I mean you know we talked about uh we
talked about you know some of the
evidence that was there uh you know
obviously the cast that's uh that phone
evidence uh was was was great evidence
um and then there were other
commonalities there were other investing
investigations but I think one of the
good things about having a task force is
basically you strip it all down and you
start from scratch and then you use the
DA's office because the DA's office has
to get you uh light the lifeblood of of
an investigation is information and the
way you get information on a cold case
is the District Attorney's Office issues
subpoenas in conjunction with the
investigators and execute search
warrants again in conjunction with the
with the um uh the investigators and
then you then you mine all that data and
then and then you let that data take you
where you need to go so that's what we
did in this case and six weeks in uh the
uh the break in the case a significant
break in the case was uh was the uh was
the Avalanche and the fact that this guy
uh you know he was described by
Witnesses and ogre he he matched the
description of the ogre and where he
lived
well I mean it was it was a lot of
things right it was it was it was his uh
physical size it was his uh where he
lived where he worked uh the fact that
his uh family members were out of the
country at the time of the commission of
the three murders uh the fact that
um he he now then you start looking into
him and then you start getting burner
phones well he has uh did we had up to
seven burner phones he's using these
fictitious email addresses
um so then so then you you follow him
and you get an abandonment sample then
you go back to some of the old evidence
so it's you know there there are there
are I mean March 14th uh 2022 was a huge
day for the task force but uh you know
it's it's never one piece of evidence
well there's I mean there's there's like
what they'll call Lawman searches and
basically what it is is you run a
certain make model of a car and certain
other you know where you live or what
you do for a living and then you get
data and then you mine that data for
something that would would uh match with
uh with your uh with your case and you
do that you don't do that just you know
you do that a hundred times you know
until until it hits until you get the
right data points
eyes if you
need each of those murder ERS so we
can't we can't talk about
um we can't talk about ethically in New
York you can't talk about any statements
the defendant made but he uh you know he
made we're not turning over any
statements uh
um I would say he was yes
yeah so that in between the in between
the bed and the and the and the cab
there's like a little triangular
uh
um ornament almost and it's it's Unique
in the way it's configured it's Unique
to to the Avalanche it was unique to the
Avalanche at that time uh and that was
something that was pointed out by by
Witnesses
well you know the investigation is is
continuing and I would never say never
um and we're going to continue to look
at again now this is a watershed event
in the in in this case uh and so we've
now uh all going out and we're we're
executing more search warrants we'll get
more information more data and you know
together uh we'll look at that and see
where it leads
I'm sorry
which uh uh so so this investigation had
to do with
um uh these these four victims so we've
been in touch with the four victims
through the grand jury uh process
um with regard to victims in general and
and other victims uh you know who lost
people in the vicinity of that area you
know we speak uh to to our victims all
the time but that that's those are
conversations that we keep between
ourselves
so uh you know it's um uh so first off
Maureen brainer Barnes she the the other
uh three one uh one was was uh was went
uh Missing in 2009 uh I believe the
others in 2010
um she was in 2007 so it was it was a
little bit more remote in time uh we are
um we are uh working through evidence a
lot of that evidence has to do with
forensic evidence uh and analyzes that
are not completed uh but once those
analyzes are completed uh we are we are
we feel good about the case and we're
going to just continue to let that
process go and again I think the the the
the
um initial plan was to allow the grand
jury investigation to go a little
further but at a certain time again the
the task force felt you know we need to
uh we we for for for reasons having
nothing to do with the evidence in the
case we need to take it down
um you know he's uh
you know it's it's it's
um as a prosecutor and as investigators
you know he is charged with a crime uh
there are certain Elements which we we
need to prove that crime we are going to
prove those elements we're going to work
hard we're going to convict him and
we're going to hold uh him responsible
for what he did and whether you know
what I think of him personally whether
I'd like him whether I don't like him
whether I doesn't matter we are going to
hold him responsible for what he did in
this case
um the grand jury is um it's a secret uh
and we're going to keep it secret
um but we have an investigation and it
is continuing
lead by the
put on it I did one of the officials
appeared to BMW
I'm sure wh or something along those
lines
obviously those guys
sure does
I mean uh you know he has an H in his
name he has uh so it's what it was hm
or wh yeah so he's got an H in his name
and other
um other relatives in his family have a
w in their name what that means
I don't know
why
there's motive I
um I think that when you look at his uh
internet searches
um you know I think that
um
provides a little uh
in insight into his state of mind and
again we don't have to probe motive we
have to prove the elements and that's
what we're going to do
this
well
uh you know you you uh you know you said
woman
um you know with regard to the sex
workers what we did was uh we we had him
under surveillance uh we had other means
of monitoring him uh and again it's uh
it's a
um it's a process and and that process
is you have to balance uh the ability to
to prove to find enough evidence to
charge him and hold them responsible
with the balance of keeping the public
safe uh and it's it's not easy uh and we
decided at a certain point in time that
the you know that we needed to take them
down because we didn't feel comfortable
with it so that's what we did
increase to give it to cause you a lot
um I don't think it was so much I don't
I don't think it was so much uh the
searches I think I think that the
conduct of the defendant was was very
consistent I think but uh the the
quality of our evidence was increasing
uh by the by the by the day by the
moment uh due to the great work of our
task force uh Partners so at a certain
point of time we're like okay uh you
know we can we can do this
murder weapon or was assault
the uh the um
I believe the the cause of death is
homicidal violence obviously given the
length of time and and and the exposure
to a very harsh environment uh
forensically their their uh was not uh
you know not a lot that that could be
done with with the remains other than uh
come to that conclusion
he has uh he has uh he has uh permits
for 92 guns he has a very large safe in
which guns are kept uh we are continuing
to
um execute search warrants so I'm sure
we'll have that uh answer shortly
I'm sorry
foreign
I think there's I think there's there's
always concerns I think you know we I I
got into office in January 22. uh we
worked with our partners we we had our
first meeting uh February 1st uh and we
worked and and you know March 14th was
really that Watershed day and when I
tell you you know I'd like to brag and
say that my office was really working
hard which we were uh but no other
agency was working any less hard than we
were once we realized what we had and we
realized the stakes all of our
partnership uh all of our partners
really worked uh I mean I I think if you
look at at the folks standing here uh I
don't think that you know in the last 48
hours any of us have gotten more than
three hours sleep
running on Maureen burn on Barnes
how much more do you touch any time
we are going to continue our
investigation and when we are prepared
when we have concluded that
investigation uh we will uh you know we
will will bring that uh to a conclusion
but we will not do it before
all right thank you
you have one more okay between all the
search warrants and this is like
you said you're gonna lose them
searching around and stuff you know I
don't want to tell you you know exact uh
investigative techniques because they're
you know again part of the reasons why
they're
um effective is because people don't
necessarily know what that uh what what
it is exactly we do but uh always a
concern but given the professionalism of
our partners uh their diligence and
their commitment uh we felt good about
about the case or keeping the case going
until we didn't and then we took it down
thank you thanks guys
yeah it's over now and we'll go rest my
foot
thank you